good morning and welcome to this
licensing act subcommittee on the 9th of
june 2022.
uh this subcommittee has been called to
determine an application for a new
premises license for the boathouse at 42
cross street
sudbury
the procedure we will follow is that
following some preliminary
administrative type matters to be dealt
with
the the hearing proper will be dealt
with by way of an informal around the
table hearing
the uh the procedures will start with
the licensing officer
summarizing the report
to the subcommittee for their
consideration there will be an option to
ask questions if there's any
clarification needed on what's what's
what's been presented
the applicant will then have the
opportunity to present their case to the
subcommittee
and again that may be followed by
questions for any clarification
matters um
following that if there is an objector
in attendance they may then make their
um or a representation based on their
written representation
and questions again may be asked then
there will be a brief summing up the the
the um the members may ask the final
questions and the applicant will have
the final say before the subcommittee go
into a private session to determine the
application
i shall go on to the election of chair
um as we have the the chair for the full
licence in the regulatory committee that
council lee parker he will be chairing
this subcommittee this morning and i now
hand over to councillor parker to take
proceedings thank you
thank you mr dulu and good morning and
welcome uh to this virtual meeting of
the licensing subcommittee
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
youtube and will be capable of repeated
viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i've got some housekeeping items if we
can
be mindful as well
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you're attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt you may
be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair please
await your turn
so moving on to item three
apologies for absence um can i ask the
governance officer to give any apologies
for absence please
no receive chair
thank you and uh declaration of interest
by councillors again to the governance
officer are there any declarations of
interest
none
from me
and uh councillor none any declarations
of interest no
excellent okay
um so what i'm going to do now is just
make some introductions um starting off
with the members of the subcommittee um
if i can i'm starting with myself my
name is lee parker councillor lee parker
i'll be chairing the the subcommittee
this morning uh and then moving on to
our vice chair councillor carpenter
yeah good morning councillor sue
carpendale uh i am vice chair of the
licensing and regulation regulatory
committee
thank you and councillor none
councillor john dunn baby district
councillor
said job and then if i can introduce the
offices that are in attendance as well
starting with our legal advisor please
yeah nigel dela legal advisor to the
subcommittee this morning
thank you and then our licensing
officers please starting with catherine
hi catherine green licensing officer
thank you
and catherine sanders
licensing officer
thank you and then our governance
officer please
good morning karen sayer governance
officer
thank you very much and then in the
background we do have another governance
officer with us as well mandy smith who
is operating the it
and
running the youtube for us in the
background good morning mandy as well
um so now if i can i'm going to ask the
applicant
please to introduce yourselves and if
you're represented ask your
representative to make the introductions
please mr pratt
hi yeah my name is dan pratt a licensee
at the boat house
in sudbury 42 cross street
and hand you over to nigel
good morning chair uh my name is nigel
derma i'm a licensing consultant uh
assisting with this application today so
wonderful thank you chance thank you
very much and can i ask you please both
to confirm receipt of procedure report
and copies of the relevant notice you
confirm that you've received those
please correctly yes we have yes
super job um now
karen can you tell us have we got
anybody else with us as yet i know we
were we were waiting for for anybody
else to to be with us
nobody else arrived in the meantime
okay all right in which case we'll uh
we'll we'll crack on um i'll just ask if
um any party that'll be the applicant um
here in this case is any party to the
hearing wishes to withdraw either their
application or their representation
mr brat
you just confirm whether you wish to
withdraw um either
no i don't i'm sorry i apologize that's
all right
um okay so i've got some questions to
the licensing officer please um
catherine have there been any requests
from the parties for permission to call
witnesses
uh no chair
excellent and have the parties indicated
they wish to present documentary or
other material
uh no chair
super job thanks very much
okay um so uh mr pratt and mr dermot
back to yourselves um could i ask you
please to estimate the time you think
you might require to present your case
uh and ask questions of any other
parties to the hearing
good morning chair yes i think uh
possibly it's going to take me just
about 15 minutes just to cover the
report which i hope you've got receipt
of together with uh two appendices
appendix a and appendix b
um it's unfortunate that some of the
residents are here because i was hoping
that we might have delayed some of their
concerns with some of the office offers
that we we're making subsequent to our
application
can we just confirm there's nobody here
president who's made representation
including the planning offices
uh yeah if we can if we can do that
please karen's governance officer
i can confirm there are no other parties
present at the moment
okay thank you um thank you mr i mean
obviously that that might change um we
might uh have somebody who comes in in a
little while sort of thing but at the
moment it's just us
we've got nothing to hide and no
objections to people joining later jolly
good thank you very much indeed okay so
moving on then to item number five the
hearing itself uh so please if i could
ask the licensing officer to present the
report b stroke la sub stroke 22 stroke
1 and to summarize the matter under
consideration please catherine
thank you chair
um this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premises license made under section 17
of the licensing act 2003 by darren
pratt in relation to the premises the
boathouse 42 cross street sudbury
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 13th of april
2022 and a copy of this is attached to
this report as appendix a
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation
the notices advertising the application
have been on display at the premises and
published in the east england daily
times 28th of april 2022 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form attached as appendix a
to this report
the operating schedule steps proposed by
the applicant to promote the four
licensing objectives are listed as
appendix b to this report
the hearing is necessary to determine
the application following receipt of 10
representations which have not been
withdrawn the subcommittee will be aware
that its consideration is confined to
promotion of the four licensing
objectives and the need or commercial
demand for licensed premises are not
considerations for the licensing
authority when discharging its licensing
functions
in carrying out its licensing functions
the licensing authority must have regard
to a statement of licensing policy
published under section 5 of the act and
any guidance issued by the secretary of
state under section 182
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act with a view
to promoting the licensing objectives
which are the prevention of crime and
disorder public safety the prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
licensing policy is inconsistent with
these revisions
in these circumstances the licensing
authority will have regard and give
appropriate weight to the relevant
changes guidance and its own statement
of licensing policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
the human rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8-1 of protocol 1 for those
raising representations when determining
applications for the grant of a new
license
the licensing authority has received one
representation from responsible
authorities under the licensing act
2003. this is attached as appendix c to
the report
after mediation between an officer from
baby district council's environmental
protection team the applicant has agreed
to amend part m conditions and this is
attached as appendix f
there has been nine representations
received made by other persons which
includes local residents businesses and
residents associations and this is
attached as appendix d to this report
to notify the subcommittee members two
representatives did withdraw their
representations initially however this
was due to misunderstanding the revised
operating schedule therefore the
representations have been readmitted
into the hearing paperwork
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take such of
the steps if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
to grant the license subject to
conditions which are consistent with the
operating schedule accompanying the
application
modified to such extent as the authority
considers appropriate for promotion of
the licensing objectives and subject to
any mandatory conditions which must be
included in the license to exclude from
the scope of the license any of the
licensable activities to which the
application relates
to refuse to specify a person in the
license as premises supervisor or to
reject the application
for these purposes conditions of the
license are modified if any of them are
altered or omitted or any new condition
is added
any party agreed by the decision taken
by the licensing authority in respect of
this application has a statutory right
of appeal to the magistrate's court and
that concludes my submission chair
excellent thank you very much indeed
catherine um okay so i'm obliged to ask
any parties if any parties to the
hearing have any questions uh of the
licensing officer at this point um so
i'm going to direct that question um
straight to yourself mr dermott have you
got any questions that you
you wish to ask
not at this stage so i'll save that for
our presentation
thank you sir um and then uh i will ask
the same question of the subcommittee so
starting with councillor carpendale do
you have any questions
just a couple briefly please chair um
[Music]
recognize the number of changes we'll
perhaps come back to that later
the uh there's a mention clearly some of
the
concerns are about noise levels and i
note that um
that there's been an agreement about
noise levels can i just ask who
has been involved in that discussion and
how those noise levels for the music
might be monitored do we know that
um i i believe the conversations um
occurred with our environmental
protection officer
and and that's they've been talking to
mr pratt and and they seem to have come
to an agreement
i believe so um councillor but it may be
a better question for for mr pratt
indeed okay we'll we'll come to that uh
in due course thank you thank you it's
my question thank you councillor um
councillor nunn do you have any
questions to the licensing officer
nothing at this stage
wonderful thank you and mr durham i
acknowledge that you just put your hand
up there but um we'll we'll return again
sir um after your um
uh representation if if we can so okay
we'll um so long as there's no other
questions to the licensing officer
we'll move on and ask the applicant or
the representative
to present your case sir please um the
applicant may call witnesses if given
permission by the subcommittee but
that's not the case here this morning so
we'll just ask you to present your case
there please
thank you uh chair um i think i might be
able
to
um
uh cover the question by the councillor
straight off uh insofar as this
application relates to premises where
there is already in place a premises
license
on that current license there are a
number of conditions
that we left out because we currently
felt that they were disproportionate and
unnecessary but through dialogue with
the environmental health we've agreed
to reinstate those conditions
onto
our application notwithstanding that
each application needs to be
judged on its own merit uh i think that
the environmental health officers uh do
speak with experience of this type of
business operating at this location
so therefore we agreed
okay thank you mister okay if i if i may
carry on then please um
so as i've already uh outlined we've
already got a premises license um which
is uh enabling us to operate at the
moment and before making the application
we consulted with the police regarding
our intentions
and they made a few comments
and we've taken those into account when
making our application
during the process of making the
application uh officers for the
licensing authority givers did give us
some
advice with regards to the application
and i think that that was with good
intentions that was not this is not
intended as a criticism they asked us to
apply from the opening hours until the
end of our intended regulated music so
that it didn't give the impression we
were starting music at 11 o'clock at
night that seemed to be
seems to make common sense but i think
perhaps some of the local residents
might have the impression that we're
going to be playing live and recorded
music all day long from 10 o'clock at
night until at the end of our initial
application we were also asked to add a
drinking up time to our opening hours
which we were quite happy to
manage from within the hours that we
were requesting but we don't want to
work against the licensing officers we
took their advice and include that but i
think you'll find
that um
later on i've got an appendix of amended
suggested amended hours and that should
cover that cover that matter so what i'm
going to do i'll just read to my report
because sometimes i feel reports can
come across a little bit cold a little
bit clinical
and some of the facts within that report
might need some clarification by your
good cells in determining this
application uh and just because the
planning officer and residents are not
here does not mean to say that we
underestimate the value of their
contribution to this process in fact
we're very mindful of it and i think
you'll find as we go through this report
that we've taken some of their concerns
into account
so
both of these matters that were raised
by licensing officers i think have
affected uh representations um but uh at
the end of the 28 day consultation
you will see we've got no
representations made by the police and
they're primarily the people concerned
with
crime and disorder
matters that were
raised by environmental health officers
have been fully addressed and we've
satisfied environmental health officers
that through the inclusion of a few
suggested additional conditions that the
licensing promotion licensing objectives
will be promoted and actually they did
make comment that they have confidence
in the fact that if things don't go
quite according to plan um that they
always have the review mechanism that
they can fall back on so that was quite
comforting from the point of view of an
applicant
therefore other than a brief
representation made on behalf of the
planning authority no other responsible
authority has made any representation
uh but a number have been made by local
residents i've been mindful of that and
i've included a few suggested additional
conditions might address some of their
concerns not least
amending some of our
hours that we've applied for
the application although we've got an
existing premises license the
application is made primarily with the
intention of distancing ourselves from
anything that might have gone beforehand
at these premises it seems quite clear
in reading the current premises license
that
there might have been some criminal
activities going on in the past that
have led to negotiations between the
police and the license holder then which
has
resulted in adding sia door staff
wearing reflective clothing the
requirement of policies numerous
policies must be about 10 different
policies i'm searching toilets recording
that every
hour
and to be honest quite a lot of
conditions that as far as we're
concerned as current operators are not
proportionate and not necessary um and
because of the impact that that would
have
in respect to the application we decided
to make a new
grant application rather than a full
variation
which meant that
mr pratt can create his own history at
this particular venue and start afresh
so that that is the intention of this
new grant application
as you're probably aware the hospitality
trade has been particularly hard hit
during the pandemic
and mr pratt is aware of the increased
trend for people to remain in the uk for
annual holidays
he has been and still is a resident in
sudbury and has been a resident in
sudbury for over 30 years and he's got
close connections in the area and
focusing now on his eventual retirement
through the operation of this business
he therefore has a vested interest in
developing and maintaining good local
relationships
with that in mind mr pratt wished to
apply for slightly more extended hours
this is a beautiful location uh right on
the edge of the river um i also holiday
in suffolk myself uh and it is a very
enjoyable space uh to holiday in um
albeit there have been some
representations made by residents and
i'll cover that just shortly
to date it should be noted that there
regardless of what may or may not have
gone on at these premises uh there has
never been an application to review any
license and i understand that if this
license is granted today
this will be the third premises license
held since the uh commencement of the
licensing act 2003.
so
just to clarify as well
baber district council uh public records
show that mr pratt uh was transferred
onto the license in january 2019.
um i don't know what date you have
before you but in fact
mr pratt has only been the premises
license holder transferred to him on the
11th of march of this year so he has
only been at these premises for three
months
mr pratt does make this application on
the basis that each application should
be considered on its uh on its own area
and as i've already covered
environmental health based their
comments uh on the experience of running
this type of business at this location
which seemed not unreasonable
in a very brief submission that was made
by the planning authority in respect of
live and recorded music we highlighted
that regulated entertainment refers only
to live and recorded music that's played
after 11 p.m and before 8am and that was
deregulated by the live music acts of
2012 and that has since been uh amended
that part of the license
therefore cannot be conditioned or hours
changed
unless there is a review application uh
before the subcommittee
and we're not aware of any review
application ever having been made before
the committee
the
planning officer's comments and those of
local residents
um
uh
we have reviewed the position in respect
of regulated entertainment in our
appendix uh b
uh where we where a look at ours and i
shall refer to that very shortly
with regard to the planning officer's
recommendations suggested uh restricted
hours relating to the sale of alcohol
there is no such recommendation in
respect of late night refreshments so he
recommends that alcohol cease at 11
o'clock and we're asking for late night
refreshments until one o'clock and he
makes no objection
um there is no evidence that's been
presented by the planning officer and no
theoretical framework
provided in in support of that
recommendation despite the fact that we
have requested on a couple of occasions
uh comment from from the planning
officer uh we've never heard but never
heard from the planning officer
uh there is no evidence that this
application if you
are of a mind to grant it will increase
any crime and disorder the police make
no representations uh the business i
would highlight is predominantly a
restaurant uh with bed and breakfast
facilities uh and the police have made
no representations although we've made
an foi request we've not had a response
from suffolk police but i have been able
to
obtain crime statistics from the police
dot uk website which shows that since
2019 there has been no recorded crime in
this area since 2019 albeit we know that
during that time it's been rather quiet
uh it should be noted there is no
recorded crime uh and those the
the statistics on that website are drawn
straight from the home office recording
system
uh
okay so mr pratt i've known him for
quite a number of years but he has been
a licensed holder for 30 years
operating mainly in the chelmsford city
area and to a lesser extent over in
ipswich he is an experienced hotelier a
bar owner and restaurateur and during
those years mr pratt has never himself
faced any application to review any
license that he's been named on
in chelmsford he did actually achieve
one of his premises he did achieve the
best bar none award
which is a home office scheme that
supports best practice it's uh it's not
found very frequently i don't think
there are any in in suffolk
but it is held up as best practice by
the home office and
uh mr pratt has hosted the local pub
watch meetings for over 20 years uh and
he's a very active participant of the
group therefore he's no stranger to the
promotion of the licensing objectives uh
and he's quite aware of his
responsibilities
he also employs my services i'm a crime
scientist with the gildando institute
and
i approached issues in a structured
problem-solving way using exactly the
same problem-solving model as used by
the local police
as it also happens i'm a former officer
in charge of the underwater search unit
and therefore able to advise mr pratt at
this particular location in respect of
water safety and i have done so
and you also know that the primary
responsible authority in respect of that
would normally be the fire service and
they've made no representations in
respect of public safety at this
location right on the edge of the river
the ability to make off sales is already
extended uh by the business and planning
act of 2020
even though that is temporary and it
comes to an end at the end of
september
however we further amended our operating
schedule
at appendix a to meet the concerns of
local residents and we do so voluntarily
following similar advice uh
to add drinking up time by the licensing
officer this may have given the
impression to be open longer than we
perhaps had initially intended
and therefore we've amended our hours so
that we manage drinking up within
whatever times you uh
consider are appropriate for this
business
we are not referring to any specific
representation made by any local
resident it's our intention to work with
local residents and not single anybody
out but we do make comment with regard
to some of the overall themes that have
been made by some of the representations
uh and we don't undermine uh the the
strength of feeling behind some of those
uh and therefore i'd just like to
comment um on some of the matters that
they have raised um
firstly with the exception of new year's
eve we have
withdrawn any request for hours in
respect of regulated entertainment in in
terms of music
um with no expectation obviously that
conditions should be applied for an
activity that has not been applied for
or authorised by the license
with regret whilst
the applicant is also
mindful of some of the local wildlife
issues this is not a matter within the
scope of the licensing objectives and
therefore not a matter for this
application that doesn't mean to say
that he's not concerned about wildlife
it's just not a matter for licensing
mr pratt offers some further conditions
in the light of some of the comments by
local residents
with the intention of satisfying them uh
with his intentions in respect of off
sales uh presently is permitted under
the business and planning act 2020 uh
there are no there are no intended sales
as if we were operating like a corner
shop
this is merely to provide an additional
service from eight o'clock in the
morning to residential guests and
rather than uh encourage people to drink
up uh and then drive home uh to be able
to reseal a bottle of wine and take half
a bottle that's undrunk take that home
with them and therefore that would be
for consumption off the premises and
fall within the scope of an off sale
the smells from
the extractor fans are a matter really
that should be referred to the
environmental services if it's
considered a statutory nuisance and no
representation was made by the
environmental health in respect to that
matter and no complaints that we can
establish have been received again we've
done an foi request in respect of
complaints for noise uh and any other
public nuisance of paper council we've
had
no response to to that request
we include a further condition in our
amended conditions at appendix aid to
satisfy representations of presidents
where they have concern that people
might migrate from sudbury come into
their premises late at night and
continue drinking that is most certainly
not uh something that we would encourage
and in order to do that you'll see that
we've suggested a condition there that
we would have no admissions after 11
o'clock apart from those that left the
premises for smoking
the license holder is taking for myself
advice in respect of water safety
there's no evidence that those attending
the this restaurant are any more likely
to be at risk from the river than
anybody else who might be boating or
otherwise enjoying leisure activities in
the area in fact i believe that there
was a recent incident uh where somebody
unfortunately was drowned but it's in no
way connected with with our premises
it is predominantly a restaurant and
it's not a city centre bar and it's not
being operated as such
mr pratt
tries to maintain an open dialogue with
local residents it's early days i think
sometimes they're reluctant to come
forward because they don't know what
sort of perception
they're going to receive
but that seems to be working
quite well
on a very slow slow basis
not as a condition but mr pat is happy
to hold regular meetings with
residents in order to listen to and
address any of their concerns um
in fact mr pratt offered such a meeting
ahead of the jubilee celebrations and
you'll see there's an additional
document that's been added to this
hearing uh relating to that weekend and
i'll cover that in two seconds
so
that really is my uh
presentation you will see
that we have
at appendix a
we have amended our operating schedule
that shows not only the agreed
additional conditions with environmental
health
but we also offer three further
conditions following representations
made by other persons i.e local
residents and appendix b
further to meet some of those concerns
you'll see that we've amended some of
our hours
um notwithstanding the fact that we
already have a premises license that
gives us
the majority of these hours
and i can discuss the different hours
that we have on the current premises
license at the moment but
as as i covered at the beginning each
application really should be
considered on its own area
i think at this particular stage um
i will i will very briefly sum up later
on but uh i doesn't i'm going to have
any questions from anybody i might take
some questions from yourself and then
just very briefly uh sum up our position
uh and i thank you for your time
excellent and uh we thank you for your
time mr very um fluent and um to the
point president thank you very much so
um as you
quite rightly say there now is the
opportunity for us to uh to go around
the table and and have questions asked
of you obviously um we only have the
license though sorry that the
subcommittee with us this morning um i
suspect uh mr dermot there will be some
questions to ask you to clarify
particularly around those amendments
that you you just mentioned um just so
that we can have some some absolute
clarity um
if i may i just um i'll just ask uh
probably our legal officer herself mr
dulu i've i noticed that you mentioned
in your presentation mr herman about the
the license being transferred um only
this year
um but in the application it says 2019
is there is there anything that we need
to draw at all from that is that okay
it's just a just an inaccuracy mr dulu
yeah that's there's no issues there
um that may be a question better for the
the light of the um the licensing
officer chair um
fine i i presume it is probably just
just now that the
cafe might be clarified fine yes please
catherine if you will thank you chair um
it seems that it's reflecting
incorrectly on the web but it's
definitely on our system and the dates
that mr denver put forward are the
correct dates so
excellent thank you very much for the
clarification thank you um right okay so
uh
let's go around the licensing
subcommittee if we can then um and if we
start perhaps with um councillor
carpendale um do you have any questions
to ask if mr dermot please um if i may
thank you chair um just uh thank you
uh for that very um helpful presentation
uh covered a lot of the points um
because of the number of um
additional conditions and so on that you
you've agreed to and offered
it would help me enormously if we could
just look at the
application itself and perhaps
annotate the document that we have
uh to show any new timings
uh where they might have changed could
you could you do that for me um on the
full report for example
it starts on page 18 where you you have
some entries
um
is that something you can do for me
just give me two seconds madam while i
find that
albeit i think actually referring to
our appendix b
is probably easier reading than the
application form yes
i i was hoping that um
i didn't want to annotate my own report
and
for some reason get it wrong so i
thought if i could have your
confirmation it it would really help me
[Music]
um it starts
at e which is live music
is there any change there at all
yes we are suggesting that we do not
need
live music this is one that the
licensing officers advised us to put
from 10 until 23 59 when in fact live
music in terms of regulated
entertainment only starts at 11
my my first submitted application said
from 2300 until 23 59 to cover that
additional hour but i do accept the view
of the licensing officers that it might
have given the impression we were
starting music at 11 o'clock at night
but legally he regulated music only
starts at 11 o'clock but we've decided
we've listened to the residents we've
decided we withdraw that and any need
that we have for live or recorded music
we can fulfill that need within
the hours before 11 o'clock
okay so um
i i could put 2 300 hours there
you can remove that entirely madam okay
lovely as as you also can for section f
because this applies to live music and
record his music
if you are aware um premises that have
got an on licence do not need
any further permissions for live and
recorded music between 8am and 11pm and
to have that amplified if need be
yeah good okay so so we can we can
withdraw that
lovely uh very helpful um
and
yeah i'm not applied for
so can i can i just yeah so can i just
go for clarification here for e and f
yep the the timings are all removed
but i believe that the seasonal
variations remain
sorry season the season of everything
sorry yes yes sir you are absolutely
right
i overlook that the only time we would
want um
regulated entertainment would be uh new
year's eve uh until new year's day until
two o'clock
the existing the existing license um
and and in appendix b we've actually
asked for christmas eve as well as new
year's eve until two o'clock on the
existing license um the authority goes
until 2 30.
so we've reduced even from the existing
licence on that matter
but do you still want the christmas eve
christmas eve and
yeah
good thank you
um
the late night refreshment you you dealt
with you covered that i think
um late night refreshment um we have i
think let me just make sure that i
haven't
changed any of the hours
uh
monday to thursday until
we've reduced that by 30 minutes
so we've we've reduced that monday to
thursday until midnight
and uh on
friday and saturday it's the same
uh
it's the same as applied for until one
o'clock
and then on the
sunday
we've actually
can i rewind on that madam
i'm looking at the hours for alcohol
so late night refreshment monday to
thursday um
the
original life is the license we haven't
run goes through five o'clock in the
morning
we ask for until half past midnight
yeah okay monday to thursday
one o'clock
on friday and saturday
and
uh
23 30 on the sunday so on the sunday
night where a concern has been raised by
a local resident that enjoys the peace
and quiet the sunday we we've pulled
that back
from uh half past midnight until half
past 11.
thank you
but but the definitive answers are
appendix
yeah yeah as i said i just wonder i
appreciate you going through the process
yeah yeah i want to be absolutely clear
for you
um
yes okay uh i think that's my questions
chair thank you
sorry councillor just to come in again
briefly on that one just for
clarification i understand it's for
indoors only as well and that's the
other change to that position late night
refreshment indoors only so yes oh
indeed yes we don't get into using the
terrorists at that time of the night
because it increases noise
so indoors only right um
okay and j uh item j on page 23 that
stays as is
uh jay the supply of alcohol madam just
to confirm yeah
supply of alcohol
till midnight monday to thursday
till one o'clock friday and saturday
and
half past i've got half past midnight
here um on a sunday but uh really i
think it's half an hour more than our
application so i think even that should
be amended to come back to 23
100 hours
so we're going to stick with 2300 hours
300 yeah okay yeah otherwise i'm asking
for more hours that would not
probably not be legal because that's not
what was consulted on
less hours is okay more hours probably
isn't
and this remains at both
on and off yeah okay
thank you very much obviously the
seasonal variations throughout
madame thank you so the um
you've got new year's day again on
section l
were you wanting to provide christmas
eve on that one as well yes please yeah
and the hours opened to the public
open to the public
whilst it's not a licensed activity in
itself uh monday through to thursday
we have
reduced that back to
midnight
okay monday thursday to midnight and on
friday and saturday again we've what
we've done is we've taken that half hour
suggested by the licensing officers for
drinking up and we'll manage that within
the time
or times that you may choose to grant us
but that will be back to uh
that will be back to one o'clock
and then and then on the sunday
until 23 30.
good
okay
that's very helpful thank you lipton
i know that
we appreciate the efforts that you need
to um to accommodate the objections i
just wanted to make quite sure that that
i knew
what the definitive um hours requests
were thank you so much thank you madam
thank you councillor calvin and um yeah
i echo your comments at the end there as
well um councillor nunn um do you have
any additional questions at this time uh
yes um because of its riverside location
um can you tell me what uh health and
safety measures are in place
if you refer to the plans you will see
there that
there are life
life belts uh situated along the uh the
cartilage of the premises um there is a
safety boat nearby um because they do
offer
some limited boating yes at some stage
so there is a safety boat nearby as well
as well as a long reach pole and a big
thanks
so it's it's not the type of scenario
that you might be thinking of where
young children might accidentally slip
into the water the picket fences quite
high uh would easily cater for quite
young children
and older
okay thank you very much and and
possibly adults as well
right
thank you
thank you
counselor nun um nothing else at this
stage counselor none no no no no
okay so um
so
if i can please mr dermott i'll just um
just just a a small piece just something
that you just said there or a response
that you gave to councillor carpendale
with regards to the drinking up you said
that you will manage the drinking up
time can you just be a bit more specific
around what what that means but how will
you manage it sure well the the addition
well it depends on how many people are
on the premises so the additional 30
minutes that licensing officer suggested
we add to the opening times we've
reduced that by 30 minutes we will
manage our times so that we're closed at
the time we save we will close
and we will manage customers to ensure
that they have either consumed
re-bottled if it's a bottle of wine uh
rather than force them to drink and jump
into a car and drive away so that's what
we mean by manage to manage it because
drinking up really isn't a licensable
activity
and this is a this is a predominantly
it's a restaurant with a small bar so
you have pre-drinks after dinner drinks
and it's got residential uh premises
above um
the last people we would want to upset
although we don't upset anybody the last
people we would want to upset are our
own customers which are directly above
the premises uh that that would not be
good business for out from our point of
view
so this is what we mean about managing
drinking uptime and so that the
licensing objectives are not being
undermined they're being promoted
together with all the signage about
leaving quietly and respectfully for the
local residents etc
wonderful wonderful thank you very much
that that answers that succinctly thank
you and um and then just a just another
piece that you mentioned in your
submission um you said that you'd made
an foi request to suffolk police and i i
guess that was an foi request in in
respect of of crime numbers yeah right
okay
that's fine yeah as we also made an foi
request of uh baba council for
complaints of noise uh and any other
statutory nuisance that might be alleged
to be committed but we've heard nothing
okay all right notice thank you thank
you very much um
right okay so
before you move on can i just uh mention
the matter of the additional document
that you were served with yesterday
yeah well actually
yeah please
because i think i think the applicant is
quite concerned that some of the uh
accusations that are made against him he
does strive to be a responsible operator
in fact i don't know if you can see it
can you
can you see that
um i mean that that is an abstract of
the
setting of the alarm system
um and i can read to that so we can show
that on friday
uh the
alarm system was fully activated and the
premises were cleared it wasn't very
busy busy albeit it was jubilee weekend
it wasn't very busy uh they were off the
premises by 20 past 11 so they would
have stopped the music cleared up tidied
up well before that uh and in fact uh my
information is that music was turned off
by 10 o'clock and so therefore what i'm
saying is i think some of the music that
may have been heard at that time of the
night was probably
resulting from some of the
private parties private events that were
going on in the local area and the same
on saturday in fact saturday was even
quieter and the alarm system was already
fully set and armed by porter past
eleven so uh
mr pratt uh
totally refutes any allegation that
there was music being played beyond 11
o'clock i'm just clearing that up for
your information sir yeah no i
appreciate that mr dermott obviously i i
suppose it's uh one of those scenarios
that unless we are all present um it's
difficult to argue either way but i
appreciate your comment absolutely
just to a certain degree we can we can
evidence what time we left the premises
okay sir all right thank you
um are you you know therein lies the nub
of things doesn't it with regards to the
representations um from uh from the
local residents and what have you but
and that'll be that'll be within our
considerations when we uh when we
deliberate outside of this meeting uh mr
mc thank you but um right sir so i do
still need to ask um uh if um uh
licensing officer catherine do you have
any questions to ask of the applicant at
this stage i do chair yes if that's okay
just for some clarification please my
name is
with regards to um live music you've
stated now that you'd like to add
christmas eve what timing is is that the
same timing as for new year's eve it is
yes please yeah okay and is that the
same for recorded music it is yeah live
and recorded music amplified and
amplified
okey-dokey
with regards to the late night
refreshment are you planning on having
um that for christmas eve as well
uh yes yeah until two
yes please okay
um
right uh the other the other question
was um late night refreshment um monday
to thursday is finishing at half past
midnight but your opening hours are
until midnight um
that seems to be
your closing before your permitted
license for hours finish
let me just double check on that one
okay that could could well be a typo
sorry what are you saying there
katherine um so you're stating now that
your opening hours are from um until
midnight but your late night refreshment
hours monday to thursday until half past
midnight so effectively it looks like
you're closing before you've finished
your permitted
late night refreshment hours
i think given that opening hours are not
a licenseable activity we will ask for
the opening hours therefore to be
adjusted in line with the late night
refreshments
okay so it would be back to
how fast yes it would be yeah okay now
that's fine that doesn't mean it would
be open the full-timers
that's fine sorry just it was just for
clarification and also um for the
seasonal variations and presumably
christmas eve and then would be until
two o'clock as well
yes please okay that's all i needed to
ask jeff
thank you fabulous thank you very much
catherine that's good good um good spot
thank you and um thank you for the
clarification mr dermott as well
um right okay is there anything
uh from
the question that catherine has just
asked is there anything that the uh
subcommittee members have to ask as a
result of those questions still
okay thank you very much indeed um okay
uh in which case then um we have asked
those questions we uh we don't have a
responsible authority present
um as far as i can tell governance
officer we still don't have any other
person's present is that correct
that's correct chair
okey dokey all right um in which case we
will go to the closing submissions then
um
so i will ask the licensing officer
catherine if you wish to give a closing
statement or to summarize any points
which need clarity
um no i think i've summarized everything
that i needed to chair thank you
thank you
uh and the same question to the
applicant in that case mr dermott do you
have
any any desire to give a closing
statement i think actually i've probably
covered our application in full the only
two points that i would like to
emphasize is the deregulation of music
issue there can be no controls
in accordance with section 177 other
than through a review
and also
the representation made by the planning
officer
whose objection is made on the basis of
residential amenity there is no that is
a planning objective it is not a
licensing objective and there is
actually a stated case of blackwood the
birmingham magistrates and birmingham
city council that refers to that
particular matter where hours and
conditions have not been set by uh the
planning permission and it's unfortunate
that the planning officer wasn't here
because he or she could have clarified
that for us mr dermott can i just
because uh mr dulu uh legal has
indicated he just wants to speak and i
suspect on that point so you come in
there nigel please
no i just wanted to backtrack a little
bit further than that um from the the
seasonal variations um looking at
appendix b
and looking at the christmas eve
um edition you've asked for the um
uh the christmas eve till 2 a.m for the
supply of alcohol
but under
um b and c the recorded music and the
live music it refers to new year's eve
only on that
can you verify that is the case
i i i did i think i did clarify at some
point yeah i think i think that new
year's eve and christmas eve i think
that was an impression on my part i do
apologize
thank you so
you're only asking for the new the for
the christmas eve for the alcohol
and you're not the best
i'm not looking for watcher i'm not
looking for recorded music or live music
on christmas we're looking for live and
recorded music late night refreshments
and alcohol until two o'clock in the
morning okay so that's an a mission from
your appendix b
it is it is okay all right thank you
yeah thank you uh mr dulu for that yeah
that's grand um uh so apologies mr
dermott so you i i've noted your
comments with regards to your um your
you know the comments from the planning
officer um so i've taken those on board
is there anything else that you wish to
add um in your closings i think i think
our submission was uh full and fairly
thorough
all right sir yeah thank you very much
indeed okay
uh in which case on that uh on the basis
that the subcommittee considers
uh that the public interest in excluding
the public outweighs the public interest
in its deliberation being held in public
it has resolved that under section
100 a
section 4 of the local government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting on the grounds that it involves
the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act on the ground set
out in regulation 14
2 of the licensing act 2003 hearings
regulations 2005.
and i'll need a member of the
subcommittee to second that motion
please
happy to second
thank you very much and council and none
you're in agreement yes
excellent in which case we will um
for the purposes
of mr pratt and mr dermot present we
will now stop the live stream and retire
to um a private teams meeting with our
legal advisor to consider the
application sir do you wish us to stay
online sir just please yes please that's
grand
okay thank you everybody for
for waiting uh the subcommittee have
considered this application uh very
carefully um and it's particularly like
that none of the objectives actually
attended today um that they have
made reference to the written
representations
uh
the
subcommittee
having considered the uh the amendments
to the application in particular the
removal of the
the licensable entertainment activities
other than the seasonal variations uh
are satisfied that this application does
promote the the licensing objectives and
are going to grant the the license um
with some variations the the variations
uh really relate to the um appendix b um
which was generally set out but slightly
amended during the subcommittee
meeting
and in particular under the supply of
alcohol
on sundays
the hours will be from 8 00 a.m until
2300.
and for
the um opening hours for the public
the uh the request was for the monday to
thursday times to go back to
midnight 30 which is which has been
granted
uh all other
requests on that as that appendix is set
out is granted there were also
consideration of other matters in
particular the conditions
and also before i get onto the
conditions
there was discussion relating to the the
smells um and it was suggested that this
was
a statutory nuisance matter
well under the um the licensing act um
nuisance it can be much more widely
interpreted and they feel that it is a
matter that can be considered by the
subcommittee however um
given all the information
before them today they don't feel that
it's
appropriate or proportionate to apply
any conditions at this time in respect
to that matter but i'm just raising that
just to highlight that it was discussed
with regard to
the conditions in the operating schedule
and particularly the amended operating
schedule there are some slight
amendments to those
under condition one the authority to
sell alcohol
the the words or other personal license
holder
will be removed as it should be for the
designated premises supervisor to to
authorize
the the sales
moving down
to
condition 12 which refers to the
provision of late night refreshments
outside areas that's to be removed
because that is now in contravention of
the
the new condition 18 which states that
late night food is consumed indoors only
so
that condition isn't relevant
obviously subsequent conditions will be
renumbered
moving down to the the last condition
which is currently condition 26 the
words as far as they have the authority
to do so shall be removed as i felt that
was
not a an appropriate wording for that
condition
the management can supervise and
disperse patrons and encourage um you
know discoveries and noise or about the
public nuisance or obviously
you know the fact that you do that
lawfully is is taken for granted
um
so and that the um
the
lice of the applicant and anyone making
a written representation to the
subcommittee has a right of appeal um
against the the decision or the
imposition of any condition and that
application for appeal should be made to
the magistrates court within 21 days of
receiving a written notification
of uh of this decision
i'll just quickly hand back to council
parker to close the meeting
lovely thank you very much uh mr dulu so
um
i believe that that concludes uh the
formal
business here this morning so it just
leaves me just to say thank you to uh
everybody that has attended um thank you
to the applicant mr pratt and um also to
uh mr dermot um and and thank you for
being so concise and and on the point
with your with your presentation uh and
also to all the officers um involved
here this morning as well and of course
to my um fellow um subcommittee members
um thank you one and all but um um
otherwise unless there's any further um
uh questions or what have you i will
draw the meeting to a close uh and wish
you all a good day thank you very much
thank you
you